Hôm nay, 2 năm năm năm 2018, công an thình vũ hế chờ biết đang tạm giữ hình sự hộ văn phương tâm
xin năm 1888, một quận mình tân thêm phố Xí Minh, quế ở phẩu lông, quận phố xôn, thêm phố hế, để điều tra về hình vì đập pháng ai vô chiếu với nổi địa thái hoạc.
Chứ đó, vào lúc 15 năm năm phố phù phùng qua, phố văn phùng tâm vụ vẻ và cầu của đại đội hủy
hủy. Còn chiếc xích tâm in ra và điều tra bức đồ của lực lượng chức năng, tại thế điều mẹ giá vụ việc
hành nhân viên bảo vệ là đảng quan năm và đảng vụ được có mặt ở hủy vụ việc thái hoạc.
Lúc vào hủy vụ việc thái hoạc, đối tượng có việc không bị thường, mỗi những viên bảo vệ đã mời đối tượng đi ra phía hộ nghỉ.
Tuy nhiên, đối tượng sau đó quay lại, lạnh vào hủy vụ chương bánh ai vô chiếu Nguyễn, là hết và sau đó làm cái vình tượng phi trước tay bây trái.
Để tránh việc đối tượng mai đậu, đập phá các hình bật chương bánh khác, những viên bảo vệ đã thích cựt từ ra,
những nhiều đối tượng đi ra bên ngoài đông thời đi thạc yêu cầu tăng cường lượng hỗ trợ.
Đến mấy hai dường mối phút đã không chia đối tượng tâm báo cho con hoàn phường đồng bà.
Lực lượng con hoàn phường đồng bà đã lập đi bản bắt người phản tượng của tăng đối với đối tượng hộ phân phương tâm.
Đi nhiên, chứ thế giới lời hai của đối tượng, sau đối tượng có việc hệ là thần, là hết nói nhạm không thể chả lối các khổ hỏi của đối chá viên.
Cơ quan kể rất đều chá công an thành phố huy đăng tính thành chiếc cầu giám định tâm tình đối với hộ phân phương tâm.
Và với hộ cùng tính kiểm sát như zinh quận phu xanh tu thập các tẻ lựa chương cưới đệ làm só vai trò.
Chứ nghiệm của các biên liên quan nhằm dạc với vụ việc thia đúng chính tự, quy định của pháp lật.
Hệ tạc, chúng tâm bảo tồn dịch của đông, vui đã chỉ đạo bảo tăng của vật cùng định huy đương hai vô chương mối về lưu dữ.
Mọc hoàn tại khó vật đúng thời đương hai vực chiếc để chiếc bày tại định tháng hoạv của phủ vụ vụ khách.